what's going on guys greg alba here
sorry for getting this up a little late
i was supposed to have like a rather
popular new guest come by but they had
to cancel at the very last second so i'm
doing solo first person to request this
was buns nation buttons nation i like
your name react to the new transformers
the last night trailer now and he also
said hope i'm the first one to tell you
and you were yeah big sack of buns it
started as a legend one of the greatest
of all those who years always kept a
city to protect us not just estimate to
arrive
kill her whoa he produces
please
[Music]
thing everyone's freaking out about lot
to hope you say brush your teeth work
hard stay with money boy an event
especially a job these are couple times
without leaders kills rapist
two words colliding goddamn
you're all that scandalously now degree
the mission of the mall in terms of type
of civilization
ouchy
how tomorrow all right not get into
cooking with everything we know and love
begins
I'm not leaving you
see very cool
everything was evident in the offering
seems over when I give it up a class
dude bribed an ad kick
[Music]
for my world today
yours must die
[Music]
Wow that is pretty suya the end there
good Ken Noland worked on the script huh
okay
okay guys notice how much the aspect
ratio kept changing throughout the
trailer
I saw a one of those behind-the-scenes
things couple with Michael Bay talking
about he they shot all of this with IMAX
cameras like a specially designed IMAX
camera for this movie I mean all the
shot other shots were yeah that's
definitely an IMAX camera they looked
amazing I just know it's the aspect
ratio kept changing a lot I'm wondering
how much it's going to happen in the
actual film now before any of you cut me
down and murder me my sleep I don't know
a lot about the Transformers you know
universe outside of the movies that have
come out I'm planning on watching the
original cartoon the movie before I
catch this film because I want to know a
little bit more about the Transformers
heard about this office being like the
Nemesis version or ever the word
sentinel prime I'm not sure which one it
is don't kill me either way what I want
to say about it is I like everything
we're getting with scary optimist in
this trailer like that limey says for my
world to live yours must die though I
actually said like shit'll through hi
poppy
it can scared me in that moment I want
to learn about optimises maker I want to
I'm interested to see all that history
I don't think Optimus is like working
with his enemies now because I mean
there's a shot of the trailer where I
think like Megatron like head-butting
off to this prime at one point I mean
they might feel a flip where Megatron's
actually helping out now my favorite
parts of the trailer were actually the
medieval parts you know it's called the
last night I kind of would have liked
like a transformers knights of the round
table movie that would have been pretty
sweet all those sequences look really
cool I know it's probably only going to
be like flashback moment but those
scenes in particular I found myself the
most drawn to actually out of this whole
trailer Anthony Hopkins every time I say
in this trailer looks more
like he's doing his Westworld thing than
ever like marky-mark new girl who he's
teamed up with the new open up the young
girl the older matching his age more I
don't know who she is she's like the hot
sexy knowledgeable business kind of
woman get that one sugar and like a
business skirt and her hair is tied up
in glasses oh man you need need that eye
candy you need a hot chicken a
Transformers movie doesn't work without
them who really gives a [ __ ] about the
robot and I feel like this trailer is
going to perform much better with Fanta
like actual fans of transformers overall
because this feels more like it you know
I really like the last trailer the the
feminist trailer I really like that one
I know like with a lot of YouTube
comments it really bagged on it I feel
like this charity to make people a lot
happier at the end of the day I'm not
gonna go watch this transformers movie
for it's awesome unique storylines and
stuff even though I know a lot of fans
are invested in all that that's why I'm
going to watch the cartoon because I
want to feel more of a you know some
type of investment in that but I'm going
to see this for the visual flair because
I honestly when I saw the behind the
scenes that little like two to three
minute video with Michael Bay talking
about through the use of IMAX cameras
that's what drew me in the most I was
like alright I guess I'm going to go
watch this on IMAX it's probably going
to be the only time I watch it in the
only way I watch it like a lot of people
didn't like age of extinction I
personally enjoyed it because I saw it
or not I'm accident I feel like I'm
going to have a similar experience I'm
hoping that in terms of storytelling
just an overall movie that this is
better I mean it is Michael Bay's fifth
time around and I tend to not really
love the films I'm only seeing each of
them once because I don't care to
revisit them you could always count on
there being cool [ __ ] there and these
films are meant to be seen in the
theaters of anything so yeah yeah it got
my [ __ ] ticket subscribe to the real
rejects shout out to all of you more
uploads probably coming later today